- This video is made possible
by Curiosity Stream and Nebula.
There's another full
length companion video
about the rights you
definitely want to exercise,
which you can access by signing up
for the Curiosity Stream Nebula bundle
for less than $15 a
year at the link below.
So it turns out that Americans,
the most free people in the
entire world, asterisks,
have a lot of lesser known rights
and freedoms as Americans.
There is a deep well of obscure rights
across these United States that are just
sitting on shelves gathering dust.
So let's talk about
more of the legal rights
that you have, but probably don't want
in any way, shape or form.
But quick legal disclaimer, as always,
this information is for educational
and entertainment purposes only,
and does not constitute legal advice.
Exercising some of the rights discussed
in this video could result in bodily harm,
drawn out litigation, or
being shunned by one's peers.
Just because you can legally do something,
doesn't mean you should.
Restrictions may apply and please consult
with your doctor and your attorney
who isn't me before attempting
any of these freedoms.
Okay, with that out of the
way, let's get started.
(gentle music)
And so we start with the Americanist
of American freedoms, the
right to own flamethrowers,
and of course, other
extremely deadly weapons.
When politicians and judges decide
the meaning of the Second Amendment,
it's often the context of determining
what types of weapons should
or should not be in the hands
of a civilian population.
That was the line pre-president Joe Biden
took in a 2019 interview
with Anderson Cooper
while arguing in favor of
an assault weapons ban.
- Look, the second amendment doesn't say
you can't restrict the kinds
of weapons people can own.
You can't buy a bazooka.
You can't have a flamethrower.
- Well actually, Mr. President,
it turns out that you
can own a flamethrower.
You also can own a bazooka
with some restrictions.
In fact, there are a
variety of high powered
and deadly weapon you can
legally own in the United States.
Under the National Firearms Act of 1934,
as revised by the Gun Control Act of 1968
and the Omnibus Crime Control
and Safe Streets Act of 1968,
individuals can legally
acquire sawed off shotguns,
any automatic weapons like machine guns
made before 1986, and destructive devices
like grenades, mortars,
and yes, even bazookas.
But I'm sorry to tell
you that these weapons,
commonly known as Title II
weapons or NFA firearms,
can only be acquired after
passing a background check,
paying a $200 transfer tax,
registering the weapon with the ATF,
and obtaining the approval
of the Attorney General.
Though, a few states like Delaware,
New York, and California
prohibit ownership
of all certain types of Title II weapons,
but most states allow
for the legal ownership
if the owner has complied
with federal registration
and taxation requirements.
Oh, and FYI, if you decide to shoot
a missile in South Carolina,
you can do it as long as
you get a permit first.
Fun fact.
Flame throws are an entirely
different animal though.
Believe it or not, there is no federal law
governing the private
use of flamethrowers,
also known as extended reach torches.
In fact, only two states in the country
have any restrictions
on flamethrowers at all,
Maryland and California.
Maryland flat out bans the device,
while California only
allows you to obtain one
if you get a permit from
the state fire marshal.
And as you may know,
Elon Musk has even gotten
into the flamethrower game
by selling his own propane powered,
not a flamethrower device,
named to head off issues
with customs officials.
However, people who have tried to take
his product overseas have often found
that customs officials disagree
that this device is not a flamethrower,
landing these people in
legal trouble abroad.
And like many other topics
discussed in this video,
you may be asking how on
earth is this possibly legal?
After all flamethrowers were
historically a weapon of war,
especially during World War II.
- [Narrator] A flame throwing tank stops
the mass funeral fire.
There is no eulogy and no mourning.
- But contrary to their portrayals
in movies and video games,
flamethrowers are classified
as tools, not weapons.
And as tools, flamethrowers
actually have a wide
variety of legitimate uses
outside of your garden variety
cartoon super villainy.
Flamethrowers can be
used to clear vegetation,
quickly melt snow from your driveway,
can be used to quickly sanitize
stadium seats in what's
known as flame polishing.
They're great for cooking steaks,
and don't tell anyone,
but they work really well
in training dogs and cats,
though it only works once.
Now, despite all of these
completely legitimate uses,
state and federal lawmakers from New York
have tried to ban the device.
In response to Musk's
not a flamethrower stunt,
New York State lawmakers introduced a bill
to outlaw flamethrowers,
though the bill remains stalled.
And in 2015, 2018, and 2020,
New York Congressman Elliot Engel
sought to outlaw the possession
or transfer of flamethrowers
via the Flamethrowers? Really? Act.
Yes, that is actually the name
of the bill that he introduced.
The bill never made it out of committee
and Congressman Engle
left Congress in 2021
after losing a primary challenge
for reasons completely
unrelated to flamethrowers.
But that takes us to your right
to secretly record your conversations
with third parties that
may or may not be related
to conversations about flamethrowers.
A common trope in film and TV involves
characters secretly recording
their own conversations
to catch a third party
admitting to criminal activity.
- It's my word against yours.
200 bucks a day, fluff.
365 days a year since I was 12.
- Actually it's your word against yours.
- So therein lies the question.
Can you actually do that?
Well, to give everyone's favorite answer,
it totally depends.
Mostly depends on
whether you are violating
any federal or state wiretapping laws.
Federal law permits the recording
of any phone call,
electronic communication,
or in person conversation including video
that captures audio with the consent
of one of the parties to the conversation,
also known as a one-party consent law.
So under a one-party consent law
you may record any conversation so long
as you are a party to that conversation.
You are that one party that can consent.
If you are not a party
to the communication,
then at least one person
must give you consent to the recording
or you may have committed the, you know,
the crime of ease dropping.
Now 38 states plus the
District of Columbia
have adopted a one-party consent law.
The remaining states though
have a two-party consent law.
Now two-party consent
is a bit of a misnomer
because you first have to get consent
to every party to that conversation.
So if there are three
parties to that conversation,
you have to get consent from all three.
And as a threshold matter,
state and federal wiretapping laws
only protect conversations
when the speaker
has a reasonable expectation of privacy
for the conversation.
So for example, even though these things
take place in public,
people do have a reasonable expectation
of privacy in a public bathroom stall
or locker room in both
audio and video recordings
in such a place would likely violate state
and federal law without
the subject's consent.
In contrast, though, a person bragging
at a private party about cheating
with a friend in a business deal,
probably couldn't claim
a wiretap violation,
even if this conversation was
recorded with a out consent.
In addition, federal law,
along with 17 one-party consent states
prohibits the recording of conversations
when done with criminal
or tortious intent.
As an example, secretly
recording a conversation
to use as blackmail would
probably not be protected.
In contrast though, a
federal appeals court
held that a son who used his phone
to secretly record a conversation
about his dying mother will
could not be federally
prosecuted for wiretapping
because the son lacked
tortious or criminal intent
independent of the recording.
Oh, and here's one more thing to consider.
If your secretly recorded phone call
takes place between two different states,
you'd better ensure that both states
are one-party consent jurisdictions
or you could find
yourself in legal trouble.
That's what happened to Linda Tripp.
Back in the 1990s, government
employee, Linda Tripp,
secretly recorded her
confidential phone calls
with former White House
intern, Monica Lewinsky,
wherein Ms. Lewinsky
provided salacious details
about her intimate relationship
with then President Bill Clinton.
Now these tapes became a public sensation
upon their release and the
fallout from the scandal
resulted in President
Clinton's impeachment,
where, of course, he was
acquitted by the Senate.
Now here's where Linda Tripp found herself
the target for prosecution.
Though, D.C. is a one-party
recording jurisdiction,
Linda Tripp recorded
her calls for Maryland,
which requires all parties to consent.
In January, 1998, Ms. Tripp turned over
the tapes to independent
counsel Kenneth Starr
and exchange for immunity.
However, Maryland prosecutors
indicted Ms. Tripp
on state wiretapping charges anyway,
arguing that federal immunity
did not extend to state violations.
But before that trial,
the judge ruled that
Ms. Lewinsky whose
testimony the state needed
to prove Tripp broke the law
would be barred from testifying.
And without their star witness,
the state dropped all
charges in May of 2000.
So your mileage may vary.
And that takes us to one of my favorite
American rights of all time.
That is the right to
steal someone's house.
Yes, that actually a thing.
One of the most important rights
that come with being a homeowner
is the right to keep unwanted intruders
off your property.
In fact, a person that knowingly enters
your property without
permission has committed
a trespass and is subject
to immediate arrest.
But here's an interesting wrinkle.
If you commit trespass
for a day, you go to jail,
but if you openly trespass for years,
well, congratulations,
you now own that land
and any buildings that are on top of it.
That's right.
You can actually crime your way
into becoming a property owner
in certain circumstances.
But fair warning, this is not an advisable
or easy way to earn title to property
as it usually takes decades of trespass
and fulfilling other state
specific requirements
for that property to
actually change ownership.
All right, so for purely
informational purposes,
here is how a would-be-house-thief
could actually do this.
Under a doctrine that's
called adverse possession,
a trespasser who continuously possesses
or occupies real property
for certain length of time
can actually acquire legal ownership
to the property that
they're illegally occupying.
To invoke adverse possessions
sufficient to get ownership,
the trespassers occupation on the land
must meet certain requirements.
It must be hostile.
It must be done without
permission of the owner.
It must be actual.
So they have to be physically present.
It has to be open and notorious,
the act trespassing can't be secret
and must be obvious to onlookers.
And the trespasser must be in possession
of the property for an
uninterrupted period of time
as prescribed by whatever
statute we're in.
The time period for
vesting varies by state,
ranging from five to 30 years,
but most commonly 10 to 20 years
is required of actual trespassing.
Some states require
payment of property taxes
during the occupation period,
others mandate physical
improvements to the land.
And some states even
require the trespasser
to produce some kind of document or deed
relating to the ownership of the property,
even if the document itself is inaccurate
or carries no legal weight.
Now you might be asking,
why in the world would every state
give people the right
to legally steal land,
albeit very, very slowly?
Well, the concept of adverse possession
actually dates back to
6th century Roman law.
Adverse possession was
designed to encourage
land owners to make beneficial
and efficient use of their land,
thereby allowing title to pass
to the individual taking care of the land
from the holder that is
effectively abandoned it.
Today the primary justification
for adverse possession is to incentivize
land owners to settle title disputes
by putting statutes of limitations
on possible litigation and possession.
In other words, if we don't
really know who owns the land,
it's a good idea to give
clean title to someone
who has had the land for a very long time
and often made improvements to it.
It removes a cloud of title.
So to summarize, I am not telling you
all to commit years of criminal trespass
to maybe acquire real property,
but if you've already been
committing criminal trespass
for decades at the very least,
now you can find out if you
accidentally have acquired
that real property, so good for you.
Now, what if I told you
you could watch another LegalEagle video,
but this time it's on the rights
you definitely wanna
exercise all the time.
Well, this full length
companion video exists
and is exclusively on Nebula.
Because sadly, if I put it on YouTube,
it would probably get demonetized
and there's no way that
you'd ever be able to see it.
But Nebula is different.
As you've probably heard by now,
Nebula is home to tons of exclusive
and ad free content like my
first full-length documentary,
"Bad Law Words Good".
My long extended interview with Mark Rober
and tons, tons more.
All of this exclusive
content is only on Nebula,
which you can get for free
with Curiosity Stream.
Of course, the reason all of these videos
are exclusively on Nebula
is because they probably
wouldn't work on YouTube
because of the way that the site works.
On the other hand, Nebula
is a different platform
without an algorithm and without any ads.
Because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment
with content and put things on there
that we couldn't put on YouTube.
It's just a platform with great
and unique content that's made
by independent educational creators,
ones you probably already know
like Tom Scott, Thomas Frank,
and Thomas Flight, as well
as lots of other people
not named Tom, like Lindsay Ellis,
Real Engineering, Wendover
Productions, and many others.
There's new exclusive content
released almost every day.
In fact, Nebula is a creator
owned and creator operated.
And by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for
iOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV, and Android TV.
And my fellow creators and
I really care about Nebula.
So we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section
devoted to unsolved mysteries in crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity Stream.
Now the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of this incredible content
is definitely through the amazing
Curiosity Stream Nebula bundle deal.
And with this current sales price,
it's less than $15 a year
to get full access to both sites.
And to be clear, that Nebula subscription
is not a trial, it's free for as long
as you are a Curiosity Stream member.
I genuinely don't know
a better deal anywhere
where you'll get two streaming sites,
both with content you'll
actually watch and enjoy
all for less than $15 a year
at the current sales price.
But what's more, signing
up will actually help
countless independent educational creators
beyond just LegalEagle.
So be sure to get this bundle deal
by clicking on the
button that's right here,
on screen right now which
will take you directly
to curiositystream.com/legaleagle,
where you can sign up.
Or you can click on the
link that's down below
in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive content,
which you should go watch right now.
Or you can click on
this playlist over here
with all of my other educational videos.
So click here or I'll see you in court.